[Music]
this is the land of luck it's so
wonderful to think outside of what we
know and to entertain the thoughts that
there is more and that there is bigger
and that there is deeper and there is
wider
we don't live in a world without
storytelling and that's the thing that
keeps the world going films can expand
what's possible and expand the
imagination and can open people's hearts
and minds luck it's incredibly uplifting
and it's incredibly positive is he
thoughtful or what and the concept just
seemed utterly bananas
luck is all about sam the unluckiest
girl in the world
oh
sorry to bother you oh how did you get
on you
[Music]
who journeys to the never before seen
land of luck and discovers really what
good luck is all about
the land of luck is in charge of
creating and randomly distributing luck
both good and bad to the human world the
luck you create today could change a
life tomorrow it's magical it's the land
of luck but it's organized now drop your
pennies and move along see you captain
do you like jokes only the funny ones
bob
bob is this very mischievous not
entirely professional worker in the land
of luck hey bob
everything okay i just uh stretching my
legs
okey-dokey sam accidentally goes through
the portal with bob
what kind of a crazy talking cat are you
a lucky scottish one obviously several
things are very critical one is to keep
good luck and bad luck separated the
tiniest amount of bad luck can shut down
our entire operation another is human
beings cannot set foot in the land of
luck what could go wrong
i love animation as a way of
storytelling because it is so
collaborative and then you get to sort
of create the world you actually create
the soul of the characters oh jeff's a
unicorn
oh you surprised my heart to stop the
very very first week on the movie when i
was trying we were trying to sort of
think about what should the story be i
asked the artists in the art department
and all the story artists to just
literally for three days come up with
drawings of good luck creatures and bad
luck creatures based on research we had
done on sort of international lucky
icons from all over the world along with
lucky numbers lucky colors we had done a
huge amount of research and that was
their first assignment just go crazy
luck is actually sort of an abstract
idea right so the biggest challenge was
coming up with the world that
represented that idea luck is very
universal
but very different in different cultures
so immediately the leprechaun came to
mind as well as the four-leaf clovers
and the pig
the land of luck it's a world of
synchronicity it's just really fun to
watch there's a choreography to it if it
wasn't lucky place it would actually be
quite treacherous and it is for sam
just how unlucky are you yeah super
duper this is an animated film but these
actors invested 500
on what is their character sam is
wonderfully determined and she is i
think extremely optimistic okay universe
i think you're pretty tough her luck
hinders her
but nevertheless she persists eva just
really gets to the heart of that
character take that universe she's
utterly delightful and you root for her
so much i found an actual lucky penny
and what did i do i flushed it down the
toilet
you did what you flushed my lucky penny
down the toilet simon is a legend he's a
comedic genius and he brings so much
life to bob what manner of crazy human
are you to play the sort of guide into
that world it just felt like a gift bob
knows the land of luck inside out he has
good ideas together they create the
perfect team with determination and
execution
we lucky ladies of stature ought to
stick together don't you think jane
found as a dragon when they told me i
was like perfect casting check mark i
love you i mean it's not every day you
get a chance to voice a dragon
named babe
i just thought that was so much fun
it's the captain i love animation so
anytime someone asks me if i want to do
an animation i say yes i love whoopi
she's a fantastic actor and has a
brilliant comedic sensibility as well
one funny you've not really seen a black
leprechaun before i haven't and i've met
many
this is one of those kind of films where
you have to watch it once just take it
in and then you can sort of concentrate
on the story sam goes on this wonderful
journey of discovering that just because
she's clumsy or things break or things
don't work out it doesn't mean that it's
her fault bad luck led me to the
luckiest thing in the world or was it
good luck love is the luckiest thing in
the world so i really want to tell that
story that everybody can feel the love
and forever family can look different
it's just a lovely story about the
importance of friendship and family and
it's a roaring adventure as well i like
the idea that we're changing hearts and
minds through this the important message
is don't give up don't ever give up
because you don't know what the future
might hold
this movie brings humanity into the idea
of making mistakes you can't plan
everything to go well and when you fall
you pick yourself up again that's life
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
you sure have bad luck sam greenfield
take that universe
oh until
i found an actual lucky penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
[Music]
and what did i do
i flushed it down the toilet
you flushed my panty down the toilet
you just
talked
wait i just need another penny
[Music]
who was with the obnoxiously long
password
[Music]
humans cannot be here where's here the
land of luck i'll leave as soon as you
give me another lucky penny you best
start blending in hello
mighty leprechaun frey line well done
nature
this is where good luck is born a dragon
she's the only creature that can sniff
out bad luck there's bad luck here too
good looking top bad luck on the bottom
the tiniest amount of bad luck can shut
down our entire operation
just how unlucky are you
oh oh no
super duper unlucky you cause a disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed
i do you and everyone else to a life of
bad luck we need to fix this
what are you doing here
good luck to us
both what about jeff on style yesterday
don't go down i have no words
[Music]
you